Good evening.
Good evening to all. Good evening, sir. Sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Uh, 7 45. We'll wait for two, three minutes.
Let there's also join. We start there. Thank you.
Afternoon. Yes. Thank you. Thank you.
Happy year 12. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, lemme start now I present my screen.
Good evening, sir. Good evening. Good evening.
So, uh,
So In, I just, uh,
let me start from here.
So in the last class, uh, what we did, we were, uh,
at the First we saw how
to build this a NN.
And if you can recall, I was showing you some demo on this,
uh, a NN with CPU, then building a
and N network with the GPU of, uh, with that F data set.
And finally, uh,
because of the over fitting problem, we were also,
we also talked how to optimize our in.
And we were talking on, uh,
and we optimized that one using, adding some dropout layer.
We added batch normalization, weight decay,
at least three types of, uh, regularization, uh, uh, layer
or parameters we optimized in order to
reduce the over fitting problem.
And that we achieved also. That was in the first half.
Then in the second half,
server was introducing the CNN network Conal neural Network.
And he, he explained that.
Uh, so what I'll do is I'll take, I'll start, uh, from this,
uh, CNN network itself a little bit, uh, so
that if you have any doubt and all you can ask me,
and I'll come back to this slide, and then we'll go
and see today, uh, the, um, one, one
of the network where we will build the CNN networks from
the, uh, in the, in the s Okay.
So that's the plan I have today.
So our whole discussion
for today's class would be based on the CNN
correlation neural network.
And yeah, that is how, so it'll go
for one or two more classes.
Maybe we'll go into the depth of the CNN as well with the
even, uh, even a little bit of complex networks.
Okay? So, uh, let us understand once, once again,
how does the CNN looks like?
What is the architecture?
What are the different layers we have in the CNN?
And we'll code that one. That is
what is the plan I have for today's class.
Okay? So, uh, if, if, uh, I think from last class,
one thing must have been clear that
the CNN overall architecture, if you will see,
it looks something like that,
what you're seeing on the screen now, okay,
this has already explained.
So if you see that, how does it work?
It takes the input here, the input is shown as image,
but the input can be anything.
The input can be text also,
or input can be, uh, uh, uh, text in the sense,
uh, the input has to be vector.
If it is a text, it'll be a one dimensional vector.
If it is an image, then it is a two
dimensional vector like metrics.
You can see that between like structure.
So that is what is the input, right?
And, uh, this input goes to, there are two layers.
Uh, two, uh, you can say that the primary layers in
between the first layer, we see it as a convolution layer,
and the second layer, we see it as a pooling layer.
Okay? And you may, uh, you can add in fact these together,
we say it as one layer, so convolution and pooling.
Then we can add one more convolution and pooling, right?
So you can see here, this is one layer, convolution
operation is happening.
Then pooling operation is happening.
Then further, there's the convolution operation is
happening, and then again, pooling layer is happening.
Likewise, you can add third, also fourth.
So you can add 50 such convolution pooling layer.
I mean, uh, yeah, that is how it, it can be like that
because a neural network, you know
that it is quite flexible.
There is no rigid, it like a structure
that you can have only one layer of the convolution
or only 10 layer of the convolution.
It's up to you how you want to build
and how you want to train.
Okay? So then once we do all this conation pooling,
conation pooling, then we have a flatten layer.
So whatever we get at the last, we say that
as a features which is extracted from this convolution
and pooling now that we first do
as a flatten, okay?
A one dimensional vector, you can understand it
because one dimensional vector can only go
to the fully connected network.
And finally, we get the output at the output layer.
So these three are the fully connected lit network
layers, right?
The input to the fully connected layers are always the one
dimensional vector, and that's why the flatten
is required in between.
So flatten is another layer,
which simply takes your two dimensional input
into one dimension.
Now, this is the, you can say that, uh, overall structure
of the CNN, where you have the input,
you have the convolution layer,
then you have a pooling layer,
then you may have one more convolution pooling, okay?
And, uh, uh, you may have few more conation pooling, but
after having this convolution pooling,
you will have one flatten layer,
and then you will have the fully connected layer.
And then here also you have quite flexibility.
You can add two layers, three L layer, four layers.
But usually the practice is people don't go more than three,
uh, three to four layers in the case of, uh, CNN,
the fully connected one.
So this is how, how, uh,
the network look like the architecture looks like.
So, uh, if you see in this whole architecture where,
and all the neurons are, you can ask, right?
The question is where and all the,
because there are multiple layers.
So, uh, is, uh, is the neuron available in all the layers?
When I say neuron, you have to recall that
what we talked about, the neuron.
About the neuron, we said
that it can do the weighted surplus bias
and then it can be followed by an activation function.
Now, if you clearly see in this particular network here,
we have the convolution plus relu.
There is one activation, which you can see here,
but when we do pooling, there is no activation as such.
Okay? Again, when we see here convolution, we,
we are also doing the relu,
but in the pooling there is no such activation.
Then we have the flatten layer
and then fully connected layer as usual.
We have seen that all these are neurons.
So obviously there is a, uh, weighted some plus bias,
and there will be one activation function which
you're using with each of these.
So now, if you can try to understand where
and all my neurons are available, you can say
that the convolution operation, what you're doing,
that is actually the neuron operation.
That is a linear operation,
and then you pass it through the nonlinearity, like relu.
So one, uh, the possibility of having the neurons, uh,
is here and the neuron, uh,
you can say the functionality is here, okay?
But then in the pooling, we don't do the operations
of the neuron in the pooling.
We don't do such operations, okay?
Uh, we simply pull, suppose we have four numbers,
I'll tell you, okay, pull the maximum one,
or if you have four numbers, I can tell you pull the minimum
one, or I can tell you, okay, pull the average one.
So the either maximum minimum
or average, all these are not the neuron, uh,
neuron, uh, functionality.
It's, it's an operation, mathematical operation, obviously,
but just, uh, just uh, um, um, some kind
of ag aggregation we are doing
and not the, uh, functionality of the neuron,
which we are performing over here.
Okay? That's the main difference between these layers, okay?
Between convolution layer and pooling layer. Okay?
So, uh, uh, what we do, uh, here we do the, uh,
weighted some plus bias, okay, in the convolution layer,
and we pass it through the activation function.
Then whatever metrics, figures as an output,
we pass it through the pooling layer.
We extract some, uh, prominent features,
and then we again pass it through the convolution layer.
Again, we do here weight some plus bias.
Again, we pass it to the pooling layer, we do the flattening
and then fully connected layer.
Now, this is the overall structure
of the convolution neural network.
Now, I'll come back to this slide.
I will just explain you a few more things.
So what happened in the convolution layer?
Uh, okay, these, these are the things we are reiterating so
that you will understand it a better way.
And then I'll stop for your questions as well.
That will finish this, uh, part.
So the idea of the convolution,
convolution is an operation, right?
We said that other day also.
So once you have the image which is given, say that here
in this particular case, the image is of size 32 across 32
and three represent, there are three channels, channels,
three channels represent that you have the colored image.
If there is one channel only, then it represents
that you have only the black and white image.
Now, that is the main difference.
So either the channel can be three or it can be one.
Usually in the case of image it can be colored
or it can be black and white, right?
Only the two possibility.
What we do in the case of convolution,
we find one filter, okay?
We find one filter. Filter is
nothing but the weight metrics.
For example, if you ask me
for this particular neuron, what is the weight metrics?
I would say weight metrics is a one dimensional vector
where you have W node, W one, and W2.
These are the weights. It's a one dimensional vector.
It's not a metrics in this particular case,
w not W one and W2.
These are the, these are the values.
So it's together if you'll represent that this is,
this is a one dimensional vector,
but here in this particular case, uh, uh,
in the convolution case, instead
of having the one dimensional vector as a weight,
we have a two dimensional vector, which we say it
as a filter or metrics, okay?
So the idea is that that that weight metrics,
which we say it as a kernel
or sometimes is will, I'll tell it as a filter that will go
and convolve on a port of an image.
Like you can see here, it comes here only in this part
of the image, it's convolve, convolve in the sense
that there is a metrics here.
Also because it is an image, there is a metrics here also
because this is also an, uh, this is the,
this is also a 2D two dimensional vector or, right?
So metrics here also here also they
just overlap on each other.
And element wise, multiplication
and addition, we do that is
what is happening in the case of the convolution.
So, and then what we do, we pass it
through the activation function.
Okay? So if you see that one, that
what exactly we do at this convolution operation,
it is nothing but what we were doing with the neuron.
Same thing. It is, it's exactly same thing, okay?
So here also we did some linear operation first, WX plus
B, and then we pass it through the activation function.
F here also, we are doing the same thing, WX plus B
and passing through the activation function.
So, uh, the only difference, if you will ask me earlier,
we were considering the entire input
and having connect, this entire input was connected
with all the, uh, uh, was connected with one neuron
with different weights.
But the only difference in the case
of convolution is instead of having the entire input,
we only, uh, go, uh, like, uh,
you can say that the chunk wise
or you can say the, uh, reason wise and we calculate
and, uh, do the same operation, WX plus B followed
by the activation function.
So each conation filter behaves like a neuron.
You can say that every convolution filter,
it's behaving like a neuron
because it does this operation, WXRP,
this is the operation we filter, which,
which it performs, okay?
And it inputs our pixel and same weights are used.
The one more thing is weights are same,
because same filters are going to be ev uh, uh, are going
to control on the entire image by changing its position.
So how does it work? Say that initially you have 32 cross,
32 cross three, this is the, uh, filter size.
Okay? So, uh, uh, what happened that, uh, first
of all, this is the MS size.
We have 32 cross, 32
and three represent the channels red, green, and blue,
because it is a color image.
What we do, we take one filter.
Now, filter size here, it is taken as five, cross five.
And here also there should be three channel,
because if it is a three channel here,
there should be three channels here,
three channels in center, there are three mattresses, okay?
When I say three channel and three mattresses
of 32 cross 32, 1 for red, one for green, one
for blue, okay?
And, uh, because they are on, on top of each other,
stacked on top of each other together,
they are making some color, okay?
Otherwise, their pixel values,
they are going from range weapons zero to 2 55 only.
Here. Also, we have such five cross, five, three different
mattresses stacked on top of each other.
So this will go here
and it'll extract, it'll convolve
and it'll give you one number.
So it'll be something like that.
This 32 cross, 32 cross three image, this is my input,
and five plus five plus three is a filter.
And this is filtering nothing but the weights. Okay?
The weights, which we learn at the back
with the back propagation, okay?
So here it'll go at a particular position or region.
In this particular whole image, convolve,
it con involves what happens.
So, uh, five cross, five cross three, these many
multiplication you do, okay?
Uh, and then you add them together
and it'll result you with one, number one scaler
because, uh, metrics, uh,
element wise multiplication you are doing
obviously with the, these journals.
So it'll result you with one number,
and that is the feature, what you're extracting out
of this particular reason.
Okay? So, uh, say that this is, this is for one such filter.
Now say that I have one more filter.
Now it's a green filter like that again,
five cross five cross three.
Now that green filter will also go in a particular region
of this particular image vol,
and it'll give you one number, okay?
One number. So what,
what it is showing in this particular slide is
as many filter, you will have those many feature map
or we say activation map, you will get,
so here one filter wa drops type blue.
So one feature map you have got for
that one filter type green.
So another filter you're getting of the green type.
Likewise, if you have third filter also,
you will get the third feature map.
So as many filter you will have those many feature
map you will get, okay?
That is the meaning of it. If you go in little
detail, then what will happen?
Suppose I have, uh, okay, before that, suppose I have six.
If we had six, five graphs, five filters, say that six
and all the six five cross five filter is being convolved
here, how many feature map we get
or activation map I gate six one, you can see
that 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
being represented with different colors.
So this is how it happens.
For every filter map, you will get one, uh, for,
for every filter, which is being convolve on this image,
you will get one activation map
or feature map, whatever you will say, okay?
That is how it's, uh, then
what we do, as, as i at it, at it shown,
you can add multiple convolution layer.
So this is one, uh, convolution,
which is happening on the original image.
Then from the original image, you'll get the feature map.
And on this also, you can add one more convolution,
you will get another feature map on this also,
you can add one more layer of convolution,
you will get another feature map and so on.
This is how you can add multiple convolution layer one
by one, one after another.
Okay? So what exactly they do?
This is what the intuition that if you have an image, so
for the first conation layer, obviously there is a pooling,
which is not shown, but then, uh, pooling, uh, most, most
of the time pooling is attached with the conation.
So first layer of the convolution try
to extract the low level features like edges.
Vertical is horizontal, is lights, uh,
slightly tilted edge and so on.
Then mid-level of features, what they do,
they combine these ass and try to get some clarity, okay?
And then the high level
of feature may be combining all these further images
and get some, some kind
of object like wheel structure or something like that.
And finally, what we do with this high level feature,
we pass it through the fully connected layer classifier.
It can say that this is of what, what, what object.
It's, this is the whole architecture of the CNN right?
Now, uh, before I stop
and you can ask me questions, uh, a few more things,
I would like to show you that suppose,
suppose I have 32 cross, 32 cross three image.
This is the size of the image,
and if I'm applying five cross, five cross three filter,
then we are going to get one output, okay?
Output. What will be the size of this output?
That is what I, I want, uh, you to understand here, okay?
So see as I said, as many filter,
you'll have those many activation map
or feature map you will get.
So here, if I'm showing you only one filter,
that means I'm going to get only one activation map, okay?
But what would be the size of this?
So that is what I'm going to explain you now.
So here it is shown as 32 cross 32, uh, uh, across three
is now, uh, now given as 28 cross.
28 cross one. One, okay? Single channel, okay?
Single channel. That is what you have to understand, okay?
Because when these two convolve on each other,
you get single number, okay?
So if suppose it is combined, uh, it'll go to any
of these location, it'll get single number.
So three channel, you'll not get,
you'll get only one channel.
So for one filter, you will get one channel. That's all.
Okay? So now the point is how it is 28 cross 28, that is
what you have to understand why the image side is reduced.
So what is happening, okay, so let us see that part.
So suppose just for the example, we have seven cross seven,
this is the size of the image,
and we are applying three cross, three filters.
So this, uh, this shaded region
where you can see the green shades.
This is where your filter is applied.
Just assume that there are some number between zero to 2 55.
That doesn't matter, right?
So here we have two numbers, one from coming from the image,
one coming from the filter, and these,
those two will multiply here also, we have two numbers, one
of the image, one for the filter, okay?
Here also here also in all the places.
So what is happening, how many multiplication you're doing,
nine multiplication, you again, three cross, three filter,
nine multiplication.
You'll do, you'll add all of them
that will result you one scaler.
So out of all these, this particular reason,
you'll extract one single feature that is a scaler value,
and that will be the output.
Then what will happen, this three cross, three filter,
which is shown here in green will stride in the right,
rightward in the right direction, okay?
Left to right. Okay, so now you can see that it'll stride.
Now you see that first, first column,
I'm not considering it has stride it to the right direction.
Again, same filter, filter.
I'm not changing means same weights,
weights I'm not changing.
We will now convolve with these three new columns.
Obviously there is one column which is new, and
because now the weights will multiply
with the different set inputs, you will also get one scaler
as an output out of this particular reason.
Then you'll strike it again.
You'll get one more output, you'll strike it again,
you'll get one more output, you'll strike it again.
You'll get one more output.
And once you suppose you have covered everything from left
to right, what is the next step?
You will go one label down means instead
of covering now first row, I'll start with the second row.
And again, in the second row, how many times you can see
that there's the first, second, third, fourth,
fifth, five time you can go from left to right.
And if I, i, if I see if I'll go one
level down, one, one row.
If I'll throw, uh, first, first I'll cover these three row,
then these three second, then these three third,
then these three fourth and these three five.
So if you go top two because seven, cross seven, right?
So left to right also you can stride
for five times top two down.
Also you can stride for five times
and hence you'll end up with five cross five, one
metrics you'll get as an output,
which will result in five, cross five.
And that is, that was the reason, okay?
Now, uh, you can see that if I will put the stride is equal
to two stride in the sense next time.
Suppose now suppose is the first reason three cross three
filter is being vol.
Next time, instead of just leaving one column,
I'll leave two column.
You can see here, see here,
this is the first region three, cross three.
Then I'll, I have left two columns, this column,
this column, and now I'm just occupying with this.
So this is called stride with two, stride
with the value two, two columns.
I'm leaving. So that, that will be true for left
to right also and top to bottom also.
And then I will have the last feature,
which I can extract will be this.
So what is happening? I can only, I can only go
and extract three different features left to right,
and even from top to bottom you can extract.
So three, cross three you'll get as an
or three, three, okay?
Now you can increase it if you will go ahead
with the stride three, stride three, then what will happen?
So this is the first reason, okay?
Now all the three, these three columns, we have to leave
and we have to shift to these three.
Okay? The second time, you will conwell on these three.
And then again these three you have to leave.
And then there is a problem.
The problem is now I left with only last column.
I can only stride. I mean I can do this as stride one time,
last time I'll be left with only a single column.
Only a single column.
Hence, I cannot strike
because I have, I need at least three columns
and three row to apply this filter,
but I'm left with only a single column and hence it'll fail.
Miss, you cannot apply the uh, three,
cross three filter with a stride.
Three on the seven cross seven image.
That is the meaning of it. That is the meaning of it. Okay?
So this is what you need to understand.
So what is happening? This is a convolution operation,
this is what happened in the convolution operation.
We go from left to right, whatever filtered size you have,
and then we go from top to down, okay?
And uh, if I'll summarize now that
for slide three will not fit, first of all,
that if someone will ask you
what will be the feature map shape, then you can always
calculate that with this, uh, example.
Always calculate that with this example. One second.
What is this? Uh,
just a second.
I'll just put it here so
that everything should be visible and
Okay.
Hmm.
So, uh, What?
Yeah, this one. Okay, you can see this.
Now, uh, I use this, this formula N,
which represents the dimension of my image, okay?
N represents the dimension of my image, right?
Means 28, cross 28, then n value will be 28, 32 across 32.
Then n value will be 32.
Now, F represents the dimension of my, uh,
filter in this particular case,
f represent dimension of my filter.
So what we do, we do n minus f divide
by stride plus one, okay?
When a stride is equal to one,
that you're just shifting one column
and one row, then anyway divide by one.
So it'll be the same quantity and minus f plus one.
If a stride is equal to two,
you'll divide by two strategical.
Three, you'll divide with the, and that is
how you will end up with a one value, which will say that,
okay, what will be the size of your feature map?
Or you can say that what is that? Uh, activation map, okay?
This is how you can get it.
So sometimes the numerical questions may come like
that, okay?
That we may give the image, uh, size.
We may give the filter size and we may ask you that, okay?
What will be the feature map size?
And you have to calculate with this simple formula,
and you can tell that one.
Okay? Now, uh, I will show you one visualization.
That is what I have planned. One second.
Uh, let me just go here, let, let just go this
and cnn, I'll stop for your question.
Just let us finish with this visualization.
I guess that will give you more clarity visualization, okay?
So there is one website, this deep lizard, uh,
where we can see these visualization.
So I will first show you the convolution same operation,
which I was showing you that visualization.
So here we'll use the f amnesty dataset, okay?
And uh, this, uh, this is the image.
This is the image, right?
So you can see that this is a black and white image.
So there is just one single channel, that's all.
And uh, this is a window right now where we are in,
and we are going to con start con revolving from here,
the filter, which we are considering is top edge filter.
So it is going to always in, in fact, I will, I will
take top is, bottom is left, is right, is so top is filter.
So it'll be, uh, extracting the horizontal, horizontal, uh,
edges from this, this whole image.
That is the role of this particular filter.
And what will happen when this, this,
this whole on this window, when this filter will convolve,
all these things will multiply.
This zero gets multiplied with minus 1.0.
This zero gets multiplied with this minus 1.0.
And so on element wise multiplication, you can see that
how many, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 3
to three filter means nine multiplication will happen.
And then you will add all those nine numbers
and you will end up with one value
that is the scaler value in this case,
because these are all zero,
so obviously you'll get zero as an output.
You can see here you are getting zero. Okay?
You're getting zero. Now, when, when you will, uh, uh,
you can say that I'll put the step.
Now this has slide it.
You see that this has slide it one first column,
it has now left, it has gone to the second column,
third column, fifth column, and three cross three
and the same three cross three window.
Now the same filter, the filter is not changing,
means weights are not changing with the same weights.
Now we are con revolving on the different reason
of this whole image.
Again, the same nine different element wise, multiplication
and their addition will happen.
You will end up with one more value called zero.
Here again, we'll do, and this will also result in zero
because all the value here also it is zero.
Now when I'll do one more time here, you see
that the first time there is one value called 0.1,
this value 0.1.
But the point is corresponding value
with which it is being multiplied is zero.
So 0.1 and zero still to zero.
So your overall result is zero. I'll do one more time.
So here also you can see that, uh,
although this is 0.7, gets multiplied with zero.
So zero 0.1 gets multiplied with zero, zero.
So output is still zero.
This time you see that the output is
0.2, why it has happened.
These three values are zero, can't do anything.
These two are zero, can't do anything.
This 0.2, you can see these 0.2 gets multiplied
with one here, and hence it represents to 0.2.
Otherwise all other values are also zero
to result, it'll have resulted.
So 0.2, this is one word,
likewise, if you'll put step, step, step.
So one by one,
what is happening is the convolution is
now it is being shown here.
My window is being lighted from left to right
with the stride is equal to one,
with the stride is equal to one.
Okay? Now I'll just keep on showing that first.
It'll stride like that from left to right, okay?
For each three graphs, three window till here,
and these are all the outputs for every convolution,
there is one scaler as an output.
You can see that once it has completed the first one,
it'll slide down.
Okay? So then it'll start from the second row onwards.
You see this. Now it has left the first row
and it has started the second,
and then it'll start again going from left to right, okay,
in the three cross three window giving you the output.
And then it'll go against slide one more
and then it'll go down.
So I'll just, uh, play.
So it'll show you the same thing
what I was just showing you.
By step by step it'll show you the same thing.
You see that the convolution operation is happening
and my filter is being conval on the image left
to right, top to bottom.
Now, this is the way the,
the convolution is happening in the two dimension.
That's why we say that it is a 2D car,
2D convolution, which is happening.
So you can see that, right?
So, uh, some, some, uh, the resulting output,
if you see there are most of the values are zero,
but some values are like, uh, uh,
red, represented with the red.
Some other values are represented with the blue.
So I said that this is the top is filter.
That means that from the image it'll identify
or it'll extract the horizontal
or mostly the top is filter the edge,
which is available here.
So this particular age, I want to identify more specifically
or this age, I want to identify there are multiple edge,
but you see that what we have extracted the top edge.
So in this whole image, the top edge, now,
you'd be surprised at what is there in
this, in these reasons.
This, this, this blue numbers,
the numbers which are represented by,
so you can see two types of numbers, right?
So numbers which are represented by uh, uh, red
and the numbers which are represented by blue.
If you'll see here carefully,
the blue numbers all are negative numbers.
All are negative numbers, okay?
This minus 2.3, this is minus 2.3,
minus 2.4 minus two point.
This is minus 2.0 here.
Also, all the blue numbers are negative.
That means that all these blue numbers are not,
the features are not the features, okay?
They are not giving any edge, uh, what is, uh, the top edge.
It is not extracting the top edge based o of this
from this particular filter.
So what happened, I explained earlier in the convolution
operation, first you do this weighted surplus bias.
Actually what you're doing is you are actually doing
the weighted surplus bias.
This is the operation which you are doing here, okay?
Means one is input, one is weight, another is input,
another is weight, another is input another.
So weighted sum you are doing correct.
Now, once you do this linear operation in the neuron,
what you do after that, you apply the activation.
Remember, an activation function was relu.
How does the relu work here?
For all these negative number, which is here represented
by blue will be zero
because for negative relu will give you zero.
And after putting the activation, the feature,
what you will get will be only left with these red numbers.
Some are more, uh, uh, red, uh, some are lighter red,
likewise, but blue value all will become zero.
So that is not the features which we
are extracting from here.
That is the meaning of it.
If I'll change the filter, say
that I will write this filter, that means that
I will have only the right side is capturing.
So I'll quickly play that so
that you can just see that, okay?
Whether it is happening. And so now you can observe
all my red values are coming in the right site.
So you can, uh, you can observe here
some somewhere it is coming here also,
which is representing this particular reason maybe.
And all the blue, uh, verticals, what you're seeing,
these are all the negative activation.
And uh, relu will anyway make them zero.
So that is not the features which will extract.
So now we are extracting the right age out of that.
And this is what is, this is
what happens in the convolution.
Now, if you can ask, okay, how many, what will be the, uh,
uh, uh, what is the size of this
and uh, what is the size of uh, this, okay, that,
that you can always, uh, that, that you can always, um,
calculate during the formula, which I was showing you there,
that n minus f plus one, n minus f plus one stride,
obviously you have to divide, okay?
But here you might have observed that it is,
it is showing where it was.
Yeah, it is showing the same size
of this size is is similar to same size.
There is a reason behind it because I have padded my, uh,
whole image with zeros on all the four sides.
So as you can see that zeros are at top, zeros are
as left side zeros are at right side.
And even the below, if you will see one more row,
that will be the zeros.
It is not shown here, here it is shown.
Oh, it, it is not shown here.
Oh, it is not zero, it's only the three site.
It is showing zero. But all the four site
we have to add zero.
So basically what is, what, what I'm trying to tell is
the feature map you can always calculate with this formula
and minus f divided by strip plus one there.
The demo, which I have shown
that is only showing you the stride is called two one.
But if you can, if you wish you can also use the stride two
then these many features you will, this is
how you can expect the features.
Now this is the convolution operation.
So, so far any question then I'll go ahead.
Uh, yes sir. Uh, sir,
where does padding come in the formula?
Oh, formula. Uh, uh, see
what happens though in the formula padding will not come.
What happens? We increase our image size.
When we do the padding, we increase our image size.
So what will happen, one more row will come,
one more column will come the same seven cross F seven image
will become eight, cross eight, okay?
Now with the eight cross eight image,
if you'll apply this three cross three
filter, then what will happen?
You can use the same formula again. Okay?
Eight minus three plus one. Okay? It become six.
So, uh, so if you want to have the same size of feature map,
uh, uh, as, as as the size of the image,
you can do the padding.
If, if one row, one column is not sufficient,
you can add two row and two column also of zeros.
So which will all, then you can use always the same formula
and you can get that that, okay,
what is the output feature map size you are getting? Okay,
Got it, sir? Uh,
I have one more question.
So how does, uh, stride affect the quality
of feature extraction?
So will there be any feature loss if we increase the
size, uh, stride value?
Correct? Definitely, definitely.
So, uh, with the stride one, we are, uh, uh,
extracting the low level features,
also very low level features also
because we are trying to extract everything stride equal
to two or three, what will happen?
It may not consider, okay?
How does these three columns are coming together
to directly jump from this column to this column?
Suppose obviously you are missing the details that
how these three columns would have been come together
and what is the output which is coming.
So the, uh, as the strategical two one, you can say
that then you extract all, all low level features,
also everything you're extracting.
But with the, as you increase the stride,
you go on extracting the high level features
and you may miss some of the things,
but having the very big sizes,
and nowadays the MS sizes are very big, right?
2 28 across to
likewise that in such cases stride is two,
one may create it little slow
that the conation operation a little slow.
And if you feel that, like for example, uh, some cases, uh,
like, uh, visit where you see this, uh, my whole
uh, uh, where it was, you see that where is the object?
Object is available in this particular reason,
it is not available here, here.
Similarly, if I, uh, select the, this data set,
this zero is represent only the rest,
every other reason are like 0, 0, 0, maybe strategical two,
one I don't want, because most of the operation,
which I'll do here, conation operation will result in zero
and it'll simply make my system little slow.
So maybe, uh, that many low level details are not required
required, but in some images where you see that every
in the image, the every object in every corner,
there are some information available.
You should go with the strategical two one
to extract all those dual level features, actually, yeah.
Okay, sir. And also you have shown that, uh, this,
there's a top edge, um, filter, right?
So, and different edges filter.
So let's say if we, if we want
to extract everything at once.
So is there any filter for that?
Oh, so usually the practice is, I will tell you
that you may have multiple conation layer at, at a time.
You can apply one filter, okay?
And extract the, uh, features
and then you'll have the next, uh, conation layer,
which will extract the other filter.
So, but I remember,
and when I was doing, uh, uh, five years,
six years back when my PhD
and all I, I do did apply in a single conation layer,
multiple, uh, multiple filters, that is also possible.
But in that case, you may have to, uh, run a loop that,
that you will still be in the same conation
and will apply many other filters also,
and then you will go further next conation.
So it is possible the answer is yes, it is possible,
but the usual practice is not like that.
The usual practice is for a single conation layer,
you apply only one type of filter
and then go for the next conation layer.
There you can change the filter, right?
And uh, likewise, yeah,
but one thing is, uh, this, no, this, uh,
right is filter bottom is filter, left is filter.
Uh, uh, uh, actually, uh, why, uh,
the notion of these filters, uh, doesn't stay as it is
when you train your convolutional
network, what does it mean?
I'll tell you, it means that, uh, see there are two things.
The first thing is you can have n number of filters,
n number of filters,
which may come at one convolution layer.
I have shown you this one.
First of all, let us understand this part as you have asked.
Uh, let us understand this particular figure.
Yeah, this figure. So I have single convolution layer
here, and this is the image I can apply six different filter
and then you will get six different features.
Map, activation map.
What you have to keep in mind is all the filters should be
of the same size.
All the filters should be of the same size.
Then you can apply as many filter you want
to one conation layer.
Also, if you wish to apply different size of the filter,
like here it is five, cross five,
but I want to apply three, cross three also, I want
to apply four cross four also in
that case the good practices go
to the next convolution layer.
And there you apply four cross four,
three cross three whatever you want.
So in a single convolution layer, you can apply
as many filter as you want,
but the size of all the filters will be same.
Okay? And the notion of like right is filter
top is filter, it is good for the demo,
but with the actual neural network, CNN, what happens,
all these filters are weights, right?
And they get initialized randomly.
You don't initialize those filter weights.
Like left is filter
or right leg filter, those weights are being
trained with the back propagation.
So that is what happened in reality.
But the demo, which I have shown
where the filter was designed just
to show you the demo, that this is what happens.
That's it. Uh, thanks for the explanation.
Yeah, thank you. Any other question?
Yes, sir. Uh, can we go to that website once?
Demo. Demo? Okay. No website, sir.
Yeah, we just this one.
So, uh, as you mentioned that each filter will be, uh,
correspond to one neuron.
So we have so much of values, output values when we are,
uh, generating, uh, the output from these filters.
So those many neurons will be there for one condition layer.
Exactly. Or it'll be multiple conation there or one No,
No. Uh, I see you
may have the multiple conversion layer also
that, that also I've said,
but when I'm, I have shown you here
that all these are output, which you're getting, yes.
Every output you can consider is coming from one neuron.
Yes. So how many sounds it'll be equal to the size
of this image in this particular
how many neurons you have in the one layer of convolution
that is, yeah.
So another question I have regarding the filter values,
but you have answered that question.
So how those filter initial values are getting generated?
So it is randomly
and, uh, it's completely Yes, that answer already asking,
Right? Right. Thank
you. Thank you,
Sir. Uh,
one more doubt, sir.
Uh, activation functions, sir, we can use multiple,
uh, activation.
It's different activation functions we can use, right, sir?
Correct. You are free to use any activation function,
but uh, they said, uh, yes, the, the good, uh,
with the CNN at least people have tried this has
worked better than any other activation function
for the convolution layer at least.
But you're free to use any other, that's that.
There is no problem in that. Yeah. Okay,
Sir. One more. So
the 28 number, how it came, sir?
Uh, so I'll go back. That is important to know.
For example here, 32 cross 32 was my input.
Now I'll apply the same n minus F plus one formula
N is the dimension of my image,
which is 32 means 32 row, 32 column.
Now, what is FF says
that it is five across five filter F means
filter, which is five.
So 32 minus 5 27 plus
1 28 because that is the,
and that, that will be the actual case.
I've shown you here that when I had here the seven cross
seven filter, how many and seven across seven image
and three across three filter, what will the size
of the feature map or features feature metrics.
So how many times it can go from left to right,
five times can go, this is first time this second, third,
fourth five left to right.
It can go five times similarly from top to bottom.
Also, it can go five times.
So five plus five will be the size of the feature map.
And that is how it has, if you use the formula
seven minus three plus one, which is five, that is
how you can always calculate.
Given the image size
and filter size, you can always calculate
what will be the size of the feature map.
Obviously there is a role of stride
and the stride role will be stride.
You always divide in the case when the stride is equal
to one, you don't consider the stride is there
because n minus a plus divided
by one will be N minus F itself,
but stride is more than one.
Then you always have to divide it. Ag shown here.
Uh, does it, uh, make sense? Yes, sir. Thank you sir.
Sir? Uh, Anisha.
Sir, I wanted to ask you that, uh, like wanted to ask again,
like for the fractions,
I did not understand actually how it works.
Like for 2.33 it'll be considered two strides.
Oh, so I have not written right?
So, uh, for fraction it doesn't work.
That's why I say fraction for three, statistical to three.
In this particular case, this
conation operation will not work.
It'll give you the error. Okay?
So it, it doesn't work for fraction. It doesn't work.
Okay. Okay. So it has to be like, like precisely correct.
In this case it has to, has
To be, uh, the results should be an in t
it cannot be fraction.
So as I've shown you here, 2.33 I should have written here,
it'll fail for statistical to three or more.
Uh, conation will not operate. Yeah.
Okay, sir. Okay, any other questions? Um,
One, one question in CNN, um, in this, uh, while, while,
while we are training this
or when we are, while we are building this, how many filters
or how many strides we will choose for a whole network?
See, uh, I'll tell, I told you, uh, that
how the CNN architecture overall looks something like
this, okay?
Uh, like this.
So you may have the image, which is 32 cross 32,
you may apply one convolution layer.
Here you'll get something feature. Mm-hmm.
You may apply one more convolution.
Then you will again get featured on that.
You can apply one more convolution.
So you can apply as many convolution, first of all.
Secondly, when you apply a particular convolution operation
on image here, here
or here, you decide it that, okay,
what is the size of the filter?
I can apply? Size of the filter is different.
Number of filters are different. Okay.
Size of the filter is five plus five. Mm-hmm.
How many I can apply? I can apply 10, 20, 30.
That is up to me. Okay.
But all the uh, filter would be of the same size.
That is what it ensures that in one convolution layer.
So you can, it, it is written here.
Six five cross five filters means six feature map.
I'll get here and here it is written
as ten five plus five filters.
That the 10 I'm going to get from here.
That is how uh, uh, that is how it happens. Okay?
I'll show you the demo also
how exactly you can code it quickly in the, yeah.
Uh, can you re-explain that one? That six and tens, sir?
So, uh, for example, why it is six here?
Yes, because to this particular input
I applied six filters, six filter of
five across five metrics or size.
You can say that. So for each filter
you have one, one output.
You can see that here I'm getting six outputs,
six metrics as an output.
Six because six filters I have applied.
But what is the size of the filter filter
When I say it is an image?
Uh, sorry, it is a metrics, weight of weight metrics.
So how many six weight metrics,
what is the size of those metrics?
Five across five. So for each filter you will get one,
one output, one, one output.
It means one, one. Uh, you can say the feature map
or metrics as an output.
Yeah. Okay.
So as many filter you will decide those many
outputs you will get as a Azure metrics.
Again, it depends on how many filters you're using. Yeah,
So I think, so it depends also sir, uh, how many
features we want to capture from the image, from depth, uh,
is it related to the and depth?
Uh, so for example, if you want to capture full, uh,
entire image, everything, then we have
to increase the filters. Sir,
That is true. That
is true. But uh, to be very frank, uh,
with when you'll have used data, network is very used.
Getting that notion is very difficult.
Whether I need 10 filters at this stage
or next I need 20 filters.
I mean that is very difficult. So you start with one number
and you see that whether it works or not, you change it.
That is what is the game.
Yes, you do not have the correct picture
that what should I keep?
But one good practice is people always increase the number
of filter like I was showing you here.
First it is six, then I have increased to 10.
In the next it'll further increased. Why? Why?
Because the formula is N minus F plus one.
So if it is 32, it goes to 28. If it is 28, it goes to 24.
You see that the MS size is decreasing slowly.
So, uh, just to have, uh, if we keep on going like that,
then at last I'll end up with one value, right?
So that's why we keep on adding the filters more fill number
of filters, more in the next two, next layer so
that I should not lose the information also.
That is, so that is one practice what we do.
Usually we increase the number of filters as we go
and add the conation layer.
Yeah, sure, sir. Okay,
Thank you sir.
Sir, what is the effect of number of strides on the output
or, uh, activation maps that we get?
Uhhuh, I said earlier.
So see what happened, uh, when the stride is called to one.
So you capture each row
and every row here, at least with the three cross,
three quilter every row with every other two row.
Okay? Side also right side also.
So you try to capture all the minute label
details also in the image.
Yeah. Okay.
But when I put a strategical to two,
like you see in this case, yes,
I jumped at least this particular row, sorry,
column has participated only once.
Okay. Okay. And uh, the number of the participation
of each row and column will reduce
Okay? In the feature
extraction.
And hence you may not get that minute level feature
as you are getting in the statistical tool one.
Oh, okay. Okay.
So if you are figured is so dense that it has lot
of information, okay, in some, some cases it is like that,
then you should keep strategical to one itself.
One, you should not take a chance.
Anything. Yeah. Yeah. I mean to understand, uh, if number
of strides are more mm-hmm.
Uh, the output image, what I get would be coser
Uh, output image, B four
Course, course image. It's not fine.
Imaging course. Ah, course.
Yeah, fine. Correct, correct, correct.
Okay. Thank you sir. Thank you.
Okay. Alright.
So hopefully you understood.
How does the convolution operation works?
This is what happens in the convolution operation.
We do the linear operation.
So convolution operation is a linear operation,
like weighted sum plus bias.
Here also we do the weighted sum.
There is a bias concept also. I, I gave the example earlier.
Bias is not being shown explicitly,
but then bias is also integrated.
Every output, when you get say that three plus three,
there is a bias which is being added, okay?
So that you have to always remember, okay?
So although it is not shown, it is happening.
So conation operation is a linear operation.
To make it non-linear.
You add the relu, the activation function.
So it is nothing but the neuron. How does it work?
So in the CNL in the convolution, this is what is the neuron
where, so this is what is the neuron is now
what we'll see that how the pooling operation works, okay?
How the pooling operation works.
And now for that, again, I'll go to the same, uh, this, this
lamu part and we go to this max pooling demo.
So here they have the max pooling demo also, uh,
what we'll do, we'll do the fullest screen.
Now, say that this is the input, okay? This is the input.
And uh, you see this, what is happening, uh,
these are the digits we have, okay?
These are the digits we have.
And, uh, all these digits, they have done it only
for the AM administrator, not the fashion administ.
So these are all the digits we have.
You can select any of these, doesn't matter.
Oh, here we have the fashion you can select.
So dataset also you can select and then filter.
You can see here also there is a concept of filter,
but these filters are not the weights.
Remember one thing we say here also it is a filter.
Height is two, weight three, two means two cross two.
And stride is written as one.
Uh, two means, uh, instead of, uh, going one by one left
to right and uh, top to bottom, it is going, uh, two,
although you can decrease it, does it matter?
Actually, you can decrease the stride is called to one also.
Okay? And if I play, see what is happening,
first I'll show you the step.
So now we are not doing the convolution operations.
So waited some plus waited some
and followed by the activation will not happen.
Simply what will happen, uh, it is showing the max pooling.
So whatever window it is selected here in this window,
it'll pull the maximum value.
So here, all the values are zero, zero is being pulled.
I'll go next here.
All the values are zero, zero is being pulled.
There is no multiplication element wise,
no activation, nothing is happening.
See the main difference. Otherwise,
it looks like the same filter con revolving on this region
there is, okay, but then there is no weighted surplus
bias followed by activation.
So these are not the neurons, okay?
These are simply one mathematical aggregation,
which you're doing simply if I go next, zero,
next 0, 0, 0 here.
Now you'll see that first time 0.2 will
come, this is the maximum.
0.2 will be extracted.
Now, next time, 0.5 is maximum 0.5 would be extracted.
Next time, 0.9 0.9, you can see that in this region also,
0.9 is maximum 0.9 is extracted.
Likewise, if you'll see it is, it is going in the same way
how we have seen for convolution.
True pooling also works in the same way, left to right, top
to bottom windows are going.
But the main difference is here, there is no, uh, neuron,
neuron operation, which is happening.
That means there is no weighted
some plus bias followed back.
Nothing is happening only in that window.
Whatever is the maximum value, it is pooling.
That's why it is known as pooling operation.
It is pooling that. Uh, yeah. Okay.
Uh, so likewise, uh, I, I, uh, there is, uh,
this is for max pooling.
You may might have the min pooling in that case.
In a particular window,
minimum value might have been extracted.
Okay? Or if you average pooling in that window,
it'll add all the four value,
because two, cross two that filter sizes here,
two cross two, it'll add and divide by four.
That will be the average pooling. Okay?
So these are all the different pooling strategies, which we,
which we have, which, which you can apply.
So pooling is, uh, a simpler operation as compared
to the convolution operation.
Let me know if you have any question on this.
So basically reducing the size,
Uh, basically reducing the size, you're correct.
So, uh, say that, oh, all these are the features only,
but then I mean here, uh, there is no, uh, uh,
the features are not, so it'll only extract.
So, uh, basically reducing the pooling operation
always reduces the size.
That is your absolutely correct Yeah,
Is it integral part of full, uh, conation
and network training part?
Or we can skip also, sir, max boom. Ah,
So max cooling, you can skip.
There is a very good question.
That is it a must having layer in the convolution?
I would say no, it is not a, it is not the compulsory layer.
You can skip the pooling layer. I mean, that's right.
Mm-hmm. So it's main idea of the pooling is
to retain the most important features
and ignore the other features, right?
Because anyway, you have used the stride.
One is called the strategical two one.
So you might have captured many
information which are redundant.
So maybe max pooling will help us
to ignore other information in that reason
and retain the maximum value
or maximum features in
that particular, that is the main idea.
So, but if you wish, you can ignore this. Pooling.
Pooling is a optional layer. It's not compulsory.
Yes. Thank you sir.
Yes. Okay.
Any other question on the pooling part?
Alright, so if there is no question,
so let me just go back here and what is the time?
Eight, six. Okay, so, uh, that's all.
Then if uh, you have understood this,
then now I will show you the same figure.
Once again, it'll make sense.
Now this one, so
what is happening once we are feeding the image the same
image, the amnesty is three.
Here it is written, plus we apply the convolution.
So what happened? Waited some plus bias followed by the loo,
and then we apply the pooling.
So pooling jobs, pooling is not a weight.
So you can skip this pooling layer if you wish.
You can keep it. Okay?
The good practice is to keep it,
but then you can always skip.
If it is not required, you can check that adding
that will help or not.
Then, then you can take a call.
But here we do the, the same functionality as we do
for the neurons at the convolution layer.
Here. Also you have, so that means
that weights are available here, not here.
Similarly, weights are available at convolution layer,
not at the pooling layer.
Okay? Once we add couple of convolution layer, then
what we do, we have that by the time we believe
that we have expected all the information, uh, spatial
special information from the figure,
and then it's time to attach the fully connected layer.
Now this is story, you know, already
how does the fully connected layer work,
but the fully connected layer will accept the
input in one dimens vector.
That's why there is a flatten layer,
which requires some between.
And you add as many fully connected
layer you want here a layer.
And then finally there will output layer.
In the output layer. You will keep as many neurons, uh,
as uh, uh, those many neurons, which is equivalent
to your number of output here, in this case, zero to 10.
So 10 outputs, you apply the sort
mass, you'll get the result.
This is what is happening. So this is uh, uh,
this is another way of showing the conation operation.
This is the kernel. See, kernel and filter.
I mean these two are being used interchangeably,
so do not get confused.
So we say that kernel is the weight metrics filter is
number of such kernels.
Otherwise people use filter, filter also
that I'm using one filter of size three, cross three,
or I can say I'm using one filter, uh,
with the kernel size three, cross three,
I mean these are all the terminology people use it.
Do not get confused with that.
It is representing the same thing. Okay?
So pulling operation, as I said,
you will apply a window in the same way
how you apply for the conation.
But here, there is no weighted surplus bias.
Only you pull the maximum number.
So in this window, three is the maximum next window,
I mean strategical to two.
You can see strategical to two, cross two.
So it'll come to this particular location.
Again, three is maximum in this location,
maximum is two in this location, maximum two.
So then it has reduced the size. It was four.
Pro rows is reduced to two, cross two.
That is what is happening.
So pooling is always used to reduce the size
and retain the more important feature.
Ignore the, uh, redundant features. That is what it says.
And that you can understand here where 3, 3 0 0,
maybe this is one of the feature which I want to retain
anyway, these towards zero,
there is nothing and this is the same.
What is three? So one
of only one value three, I'm retaining other value.
So it makes sense, okay?
Right? And then as I said, then there is a flatten layer
and uh, it'll give you thought.
Alright? Uh, so now
I'll show you the demo for this.
Uh, it was here. Okay?
First I'll show you the demo, uh, quickly. So it's eight 15.
Uh, so now this is my, uh, code.
Uh, I, I mean, uh, uh, I have already, uh,
in the previous slide when I, I shared,
I have shared the data set of fmni in that, uh, slide.
Okay? I believe you must have practiced it.
It suppose not you do it later, but the dataset is the same.
The complete train file I'm using, uh, here in this case,
only thing is few changes I'll show you
with respect to A and n.
So if you see that this is the final
code which I had shown you, uh, in the previous class,
we built the a and n network
and we optimized it to, uh,
address the over fitting problem.
Why I say over fitting,
because you see that here, uh,
uh, here.
Uh, uh, when we were
building the a NN network on the GPU
with a complete data set, we, we, uh, observed that that,
uh, my evaluation accuracy was coming as 0.88 means 88%
around, but my training accuracy was coming as 98%.
There was a huge difference between training
and uh, evaluation.
So we understood that there is
over fitting, which is happening.
So if these two accuracy are not trained,
means your model doesn't behave same, uh, at train time
and test time, then it is having high variance
and it is not good for the, uh, machine learning,
it's not reliable network.
Then, then what we did, we optimized it.
How did we optimize?
So you see that when we were getting this 88 98 variance,
then our model was like this.
In our model we had linear layer,
which is a fully connected layer followed by activation.
Then one more linear layer followed by activation,
and finally the output layer.
This is the simplest network, what we used with GPU.
But when we addressed this fitting problem,
we added few more layer.
We added the batch normalization.
We added the dropout here also in the second, uh,
hidden layer, we added the batch normalization,
we added a dropout.
And finally the output layer, we don't add anything
and we, we, so this is, this was the major change.
You can only change, you can say that.
And one more change we did in terms of this weight decay,
which is L two normalization three change we did
and it controlled our foot
or fitting problem a little bit earlier.
The evaluation accuracy was 88, which is still here, 88.
The training accuracy was 98, which has now reduced to 93.
So in a way, we have uh,
now made these two accuracy closer means training accuracy
and evaluation accuracy.
Still there is a problem over fitting problem,
but now we have controlled it a little bit
as compared to the previous case.
Obviously my accuracy of the training time has reduced,
but that is okay as long as it is
becoming more reliable, right?
So reliable network is is better than, than the over fitting
case where the training accuracy is very high.
Testing accuracy is very, okay.
Now what we are trying to do is
with the CNN in the CNN everything, you will see
that in the coding is same two place.
There. You will change, first of all, network will change.
Now we'll have the CNN network integrated.
Secondly, you will also see that in the a NN case,
the input was given as one dimensional vector
because my dataset has the pixel value,
the original dataset,
this trained csv, it has a pixel value.
It is not a image, right?
So original data set is in the form
of one dimensional vector.
So each row is representing one image
with the one dimensional vector.
Why? Because we have to feed it to A-N-N-E-N-N always accept
single vector as an input.
It doesn't accept two dimension like image,
like metrics and all.
Uh, uh, so what we did here,
you can see that uh, this is what we fit to the ENN.
Obviously here we have just plotted those each row to
show it as, but actual dataset was
the one-dimensional vector.
But now in the CNN we can, we will not feed it like that.
In the CNN, the main idea is to feed the image
as image means as two dimensional
vector as a metrics, right?
So that is what is the effort which we have to make.
So first change. Now if I'm showing you here, this is kuda
what the GPU is still, we are using,
we are reading the data in the same way, right?
Shape of the data is same 60,000 across 7 85.
This is just to display some of the image here.
Train test is split where first we identify the columns,
which are participating as features and columns only.
First column is participating as label.
Then we do the trend tester split.
And this is why where we do the normalization of features
between zero to 2 55 to zero to one three till this,
there is no change in my code.
Now first change, you will see here when we are defining our
custom class, because custom class is the one where, uh,
custom data sets class is the one where you uh, actually say
how you are going to load the data.
In the case of a NN, you loaded the data
as one dimensional vector because
because of the nature of the architecture of a NN,
that it accept only one dimensional input.
Now, CNN can accept two dimensional,
so you should load the data as two dimensional, right?
But my actual data is only one dimensional data.
It's a ROIs data, right? It's not like row and column both.
It's a ROIs data. So we have
to convert the shape of the data.
That is what you see here. Major change here.
One of the changes earlier case when I was loading my data,
I converted the features into tensor.
That's all obviously the type 4 32.
Now when I'm loading my data, converting it as a tensor,
but also reshaping.
Now this is one change you see in terms of loading the data.
That means that now I will be loading
or giving, feeding the data as two dimensions.
So you see that my one dimensional value was
7 84 74 pixels, right?
Uh, you can see here the size shape I have shown.
7 85 we first column I have separated as label.
So 7 84 and if you convert them into two dimension,
it did nothing but 28 cross 28.
So my MS size is 28 cross 20. That is what we are reshaping.
Now what are these two numbers then?
So this number one here is representing
that I have a single channel,
obviously only single row representing each image.
And if each image is a black
and white image, so it is a single channel image.
It's not a three channel image
where you have the colored image as an input.
So this one representative is a single channel image, okay?
And what it is minus one representing this is just notional
here for batch size
because later on when we'll do the data loader class,
call the data class, we'll pass batch size equal
to 32 60,000 data.
We are right and we were dividing it in the batch of 32.
32, 32, right?
So here, just as a notional, we are saying
that there is some batch size which is going to come,
which we define here in this data loader class.
So you can see are four things.
First one, say the batch size.
Second one say how many channels are there in your image?
Third and fourth are the size of the image. 28 across 28.
Okay? So this is the first change which we do at the time
of data loading with this constructor calling
and this length class
and gate item class, as I explained earlier, will be called
by the data in order class.
The data loader class will call the length.
It'll get to know that with this size then
how many images are possible,
and then make the mini badge of 32.
So that's why it required this length.
And once it'll create those batches,
then let us fetch those images
and for fetching those images, we required this key item
because gate item will actually give me the zero image
number, zero image number one image number two,
by passing the index.
That's why these two extra methods we have defined in the
custom data, which is called internally
by this data loader class.
And hence we create this train loader and test loader. Okay?
Now remember my data is no more a single dimension.
It is an image because we have always already reshaped it.
Okay? Now what we do,
one more change is required data is ready.
Now you have to define your neural network.
Now in the neural network, what happened, uh,
I was showing I am going to build this neural network,
this neural network where my image will be one
because single channel 28 across 28,
I'll put first layer of convolution
and then followed by max pooling.
Then I'll put second layer of convolution
followed by max pooling.
That's all only two layers of convolution and max phoning.
Then we'll have one feature map.
Uh, there will be some size, there will be, uh, some size
of the sensor, which I will flatten.
I'll pass it to two hidden layer, 1 28 neuron.
Here we'll have 64 neuron.
And finally, the output layer with the 10 neuron say
that this architecture I want to build in PyTorch.
Okay? Earlier I was only having this architecture, a NN.
Now I'm just adding CNN.
So if you see this particular architecture,
clearly there are two parts in this architecture.
The first part we are doing the feature extraction
with the CNN means convolution and pooling.
And the second part we are doing the classification
with the ENL fully connected layer.
So while uh, the designing this, this kind of uh,
CNN architecture, what we'll do is we'll use two sequential
container, sequential container.
Because these layers are connected in a sequence,
all these layers are connected in a sequence only change.
What is happening is here, once we get the image, we have
to flatten and then it'll go as an input.
So there is no operation which is happening here.
Only thing is we are converting the shape 2D
into 1D in this part.
That's why this whole part I will keep in once container.
So container's job is one layer output
would be second layer input.
This layer output would be this layer output.
So feature extraction will do once
and then fully connected will do once.
Okay, that is what is the idea.
Now you can see the same here.
First of all, I'm starting with the features.
So this container till here I'm saying it is a feature
extraction container, which is sequential container.
First time adding the con 2D, layer two DY
because two dimensional convolution is going to happen.
There is a con 1D function also, which is used with the
text data when you do the convolution
with the one dimensional, one dimensional itself.
I'll explain that later if it is required.
So here we are calling convo 2D from the NN module.
We have to tell what is the size,
what is the input features.
So input features here will accept it tells that, okay,
how many, what is the, you can say that uh, uh,
channels you have, we have already defined it.
The channels are one, it's a gray scale image.
So input, uh, features will actually, we have
to pass here how many channels you have.
If you take a color image, we'll pass three.
If it is a black
and white image, it will, you have to pass, uh, one.
That's all. Okay, now what is 32?
Okay, it, it tells that here,
let me just explain with this.
So maybe it'll be more clear little bit.
So I'm using the same here where we have the input channel,
output channel, these are all the parameters which we have
to define kernel size, stride padding bias.
Okay? So input channel number of input channel.
That is what it say three channel or one channel only.
These two possibility we have in our case,
it'll be one output channel will be uh, set by
how many filters you are using
because I said you know, right?
If you'll define 32, that means 32 feature maps,
you will get 32 features means ma
feature metrics you will get.
So output channel will defer, uh, you will set, uh,
as equivalent to the number of filters you are going to use.
What will be the size of the filter
that will be decided by this code.
Each filter of the size three, cross three say
that in this particular layer, stride is equal to one.
I guess this is clear to you padding.
When I say zero, what we do
after applying the convolution, usually my MS size reduce it
and minus f plus one.
If I don't want my MS size to be reduced, I'll add some
rows and column with zeros.
So it calls zero padding.
It's called zero padding so that my MS size will not reduce.
Okay? Our feature and sage will be same many times
padding is called to same.
That is what is the function.
Uh, that is what is the parameter.
You can use bias if you want to use it. Uh, it is true.
So most of the time we make it true.
This is what I was explaining here in this
whole, this is what we are doing.
So input feature will tell how many uh, channels you have.
This is how many filters you're using.
Each filter sort of size three across three padding is same.
That means that after conation, I want the feature size
to be same as my input size.
Then pad is equal to say that is what you have to say. Okay?
So once convolution is done, you apply relu, okay?
Because convolution is a linear operation to relu,
non-linearity batch normalization you apply just
because you want to control the over fitting problem.
Otherwise it's not required here.
So after convolution in relu you can also
apply the max pooling.
So try difficult to two ker sizes, two cross two.
So it'll reduce the dimension.
Suppose here 32 uh,
features you will get feature map you'll get,
it'll reduce it to 16 because stride is called to two.
Stride is equal to two. That means 32 by two.
Those many features you will left with.
Now this completes the one layer of convolution.
Similarly, I have another layer of convolution
because this is what we decided earlier, right?
So know in our network we'll have one convolution max.
Then again we'll have one more convolution layer
and then max, so just copy paste it.
Only differences. Now 32, uh,
was the uh, uh,
was the input which is coming from this one.
So output, which is coming from this one can, uh, is going
to be the, uh, you can say that the, uh, input
for the next convolution.
Yeah, 32 cross 32, uh, sorry, uh, the
convolution, yeah, 32.
So you will have the, this number
of input would be 32, 64 will be the number of,
you can say that the filters kernel size again, three,
which you can change for cross four.
So you can do, but here it is kept as three.
So everything is same. Only thing is here.
The number of filters is increased.
Padding is same, then relu, then rationalization
and max pooling again, we are doing, so yeah,
two layers of convolution.
We have kept in one container
that is called features followed by it.
What we have seen, we have one flatten layer
and then two hidden layer and one output layer.
Okay? And that is what we are going to see next.
We have one more sequential container.
This container damage classifier.
First we do the flatten layer
and then we have the first hidden layer
to this first hidden layer.
The input is 64 cross seven, cross seven.
Now, uh, how does this 64 cross seven, cross seven has come.
So first of all, you have to understand this, that 64 number
of features metrics you will get from the last
convolution layer.
64 number of features.
Each feature size would be seven across seven.
After passing through this convolution,
each feature size would be 64.
Number of feature metrics, you will get 64 numbers.
Now what will be the size of those feature metrics?
Seven across seven. That's why this will be 64 across seven.
Across seven. Okay.
I know there might be little difficulty
in understanding that part.
So what is happening here is, let me explain it once again.
Here we are having 32 filters.
32 filters means here what will be the size
after the max pooling, what will be the size?
So after the max pooling, you will get 32 features here,
32 metrics mattresses,
and uh, if it is a zero padding,
zero padding means you are using the formula
and minus F plus one and minus F plus one, okay?
With one stride. That is what you're using.
So here what you will get 32, uh, 28 was the
MS size 3 28 minus three plus one.
Okay, so how much? It'll be 26. So 26.
So how 26 across 26 will be the size
of each feature map here.
And how many such feature maps? 32. 32.
Because 32 filters you're applying here are you getting,
so then that 26 to 26, you'll pass it
through this max pooling, which will reduce it to
13 across 13 because two strategical two.
But how many? Such 32 will be 32.
Such, uh, feature map you will remain 32 filter, uh,
feature map with 16 cross 16 sites,
16 across 16 sites of the metrics.
Okay? And then you apply the same uh, here, uh,
32 across 32 across 16.
That is what you have. You apply with the 64 filters.
64 filters.
So 64 filters means then 64 feature metrics,
you will get 64 feature metrics you will get, okay?
And it was each of them was like 16 cross 16 here.
Uh, right. And that,
that 16 minus three plus one will remain age 14,
16 minus three plus one will remain age 14
and then 14 cross 14, when you'll apply with the stride,
it'll be seven, cross seven and 64 will carry from here.
64. 64.
That's why the size of this sensor will be 64 across seven.
Across seven. Okay, let me write it here. For how much time?
Yeah, we have some time.
So what is happening here is uh, uh,
okay, so what is happening here is, so you're applying 32.
So here our size of the image 28 across 28, okay,
applying three cross three filters.
So normal. So what will happen
and minus f plus one, this is the formula.
What we are using N okay, N is here 28 minus
FF here is three
because three cross three filter plus one, okay?
Plus one.
So it what will be remain here
and 28 minus three plus one is 26.
So now whatever feature you will get here, that will be
of size 26 cross 26.
How many, how many such features you will get 32 filters.
32 filters you're applying means 32 such features,
you will get 32.
Such features you will get, okay, now coming, coming
to max layer, what will happen,
because you're applying a stride is equal to two,
this 20 clause 26 core 26 will be reduced to 13 clause 13
because stride is equal to two.
So you can simply divide it by two
and you will left here with 13 across 13.
This is the size I'm talking, this is the size
of the feature, uh, features what you are left with,
how many you are still having 32
because 32 filters you have used, you're still having 32 uh,
such, uh, uh, features, uh,
feature feature metrics.
You have 30 13, column 13 is a size 13 to 13 column.
But how many? 32. Now you apply again convolution.
So what happened in the convolution, again,
you do n minus f plus one size of the image is 13 plus 13.
13 minus three plus one. Okay?
So, uh, uh, 20, sorry,
here 28, 26, 26, uh, means, uh, 13, 13,
uh, 13 minus three plus one.
Suppose you are doing to 13 minus three is equal to 10.
So you will left here with 11.
I guess in that case you'll have to hear with 11, okay?
11 cross level will be the size of the image. How many?
64 filters be 64?
Such filters means features you will remain with.
Now if you'll apply here, two, cross two, you have
to divide it by two.
That is what is the rule? That is what is the rule. Okay?
So that is what I'm doing here.
There is some mismatch I understand.
So from 28 we will come to the 26
and uh, strategical to two.
So, uh, I should, uh, 28. Okay?
Uh, so this is, uh,
this calculation here is different from here.
Why I will tell you because, sorry, lemme just close.
Lemme just erase this. Everything.
So what is here is here.
If you see in our implementation, you will see
that here I end up with 64 plus seven plus seven.
But there it was a fraction which is coming at the last
difference is here.
Padding is equal to same.
When do padding is equal to same size doesn't change.
Means if you start with 32 filters here, uh,
but means 28 cross 28 here also you end up
with 28 cross 28 in this particular layer.
But this 28 cross 28 divided by two will remain 14,
cross 14, okay?
Now 14, cross 14 here will remain based, uh, uh, uh,
like say, uh, 28, 28, 14
and 14, uh, will remain 14 here
and that will be divided here will remain seven plus seven.
That's why you are left with 64 into seven into seven.
That is the size of this particular tensor,
which we are flattening.
And that is what you can see here.
So that then the, into the, to to my first hidden layer
to this particular hidden layer,
what is the size of this flatten layer?
It is like 20, uh, what is that?
64 across seven across seven.
Those many inputs we are going to feed,
that is what is written here.
Then in the first hidden layer, 1 28 euro applying relu, uh,
here also and drop out.
Then in the second hidden layer from 1 28 inputs, we go
to 64 neuron dropout.
And from 64 we go to 10. Okay?
So this is my three fully connected layer,
what you can see here, and that is what is being applied.
That is what is being applied.
This is the another change you do as compared to your a NN
uh, a n code.
So we have built here this network, okay?
It looks difficult, right? But we have built,
that's all rest, all the code will be same
learning rate apoch, my NN uh, everything is same.
In fact, training loop is same, no change.
Only thing my network has changed. No. Okay? Uh, that's all.
But both, both of these function, you see
that it is coming one after other in the constructor.
So whenever we'll create an object of it,
constructed will get called first.
This will get executed,
then this will get executed automatically in a sequence.
Okay? So that's all.
And then you will end up, uh, with what you will create, uh,
the training loop, no change.
And if you see here only 20 epoch,
because it was taking a little more time, a lot
of calculations were happening right then, uh, when I, uh,
stopped it after 20 epoch, this is what was the situation.
My training accuracy was 97%.
Again, training accuracy jumped from 93 to 97,
but evaluation accuracy has also jumped from
89 88 to 92.
So the gap, if you'll see is still there is a 5%.
So word fitting is still there. Okay?
I, we have to do something to reduce this over fitting,
but accuracy has increased with the CNN
because now it has understood image
as a data rather than just one dimens input as a data.
So this is what is the, I'll stop here
for your questions, okay?
And we'll see the next thing in the next class.
Sir, one quick question here, sir for a second.
Conventional here, do we need to always increase the number
of filters, sir?
Uh, why we do,
because, uh, I mean it's a good practice, although it is not.
It's again, it's your wish.
How many filters you want to add here?
Here we have added 64.
Yes Sir. You could have done, you can could have stayed
32 could have reduced it.
Also, only challenge would be if you reduce
here, now what will happen?
You are following it by max pooling where strategical
to two, it'll further reduce the size of your
what distance, sir.
Finally, what you're going to get, it should not happen
that you are end up here with a zero value, A zero features
because the, the nature of the CNN
and pooling it, it'll reduce the size of the input.
So if I have shown here only two layers,
but you can add 10 layers also, if you will not maintain
that increasing number of filter, then overall at last,
what you will end up with this,
this sensor will have very small size or almost wrong.
Almost it'll be zero because it directly divided by two.
So 64, 20, 28 got divided
by 2 14, 4 14 got divided by two seven.
One more layer. If I add, I almost will be one
or two if I don't increase the conation filter here.
That's why that's a good practice to add the con filter.
But if you're sufficient, if you are assured
that my MS size is too big
and with two layers of convolution I want, uh, big, uh,
getting into that particular problem,
then you can keep the same normal filter.
Does it matter? Yeah, matter.
Yeah, sure, sir. Thank you sir.
Well, one more do that, uh,
after the, uh, from two dimensional
to one dimensional array, where in flattening means, uh,
the dimensional will go up.
Now, if that, uh, minus is increasing
This much, this, the dimension
of the platinum input will be 64 across sims, across seven,
these many, but that doesn't matter, right?
We will connect it with the fully connected
layer, we'll process it.
Those many weights would be required obviously. Yeah.
How many weights would be here?
64 cross seven, cross seven into 1 28. Yes.
So yeah, parameters would be here too much.
That is true, but yeah, we can process it
with the system what we have here.
Okay,
others?
Any question? Does it making sense that how
to build the c nnn?
What is going inside?
What is convolution layer, pooling layer
or it is going on the top?
Yes, sir.
It's making some sense. Making some sense. Okay.
We need to hear another two, three times of this, it'll,
Okay. Okay. So
for
Example, padding is done for, uh, three times, right?
Like uh, three cross, uh, like it is increased three times.
That means uh, the input is made to 34,
right? 34 cross
34, 28 we started the MS size, correct?
28 cross 28, 32,
Sir? No,
no. In this example it was 28 only.
I mean in the, it's 28 PPTI showed you 32, correct?
But then in this example it was just,
uh, it is, it is 28, cross 28 because 7 84 pixels, right?
Okay. 7 7 84 pixels. It's 28 plus 28 here.
Yes sir. Okay. Yeah.
So what was the question?
Uh, no sir. I think, uh, pretty much it.
Okay.
Okay. So one thing
before, we'll close these CNNs are good when you have this
great sort of data when image data
where we would've passed one dimension also,
which we have done in the case of PNN,
but then spatial features, region wise features
because those, that in
that region only the pixel values is high.
Rest of the reason is it's zero.
So we are giving the special focus to
that region while extracting the features.
That is what makes the CNN different from the a NN,
which is required in the case of images.
Okay? And that's why it is performing little better.
You have seen that my training
and validation, both accuracy has jumped.
Obviously there is over fitting problem,
which we'll see in the coming classes how
to overcome with that.
Yeah. Okay, sure sir. Yeah.
And tomorrow there is no class.
And the two more announcement on Monday,
we'll release the, uh, assignment.
Assignment will be the coding based assignment
where we may ask you to build some CNN based networks,
including an a NN write and do some tasks.
We'll give you the data set, which will be common,
but you're free to build any kind of CNN network
and we'll collect, we'll give you two weeks time from the
next Monday, 15 days time to submit your assignment.
Okay? Second announcement is next Saturday.
This Saturday you don't have
class tomorrow, you don't have class.
Next Saturday you will have the mid-semester examination.
Okay, because we are now ending the seventh week.
So we are now have to have the mid-semester examination.
What's the format? Uh, sim semester,
Mid sim will be again, uh, again, uh, multi m CQ based.
Okay. Yeah.
Only the end semester will be descriptive as we did
for the MLP will go in the same way.
Otherwise, uh, m mid semester will also will be MCQ
portions will be complete CNN part
availability extra obviously.
Yeah. But then portions will be complete.
We'll repeat it on the Monday also,
but, uh, I just thought of telling you today, sir.
Okay?
Yes. May 10th, uh,
10th of January it'll be sir
10th? Yes. Next
day, correct? Correct.
The kind request, uh,
timing should be preferable in the evening
because Saturday also we're working.
Oh, okay. Okay. So you don't want, but whatever.
I thought that during the class hour
itself, we can conduct that.
Uh, that would be fine, sir.
But Saturday, uh, it's nine to 10 30 of class,
but we are working on that day.
I mean, every Saturday we work.
Mm-hmm. Okay.
Then we'll see that will, but Saturday will be the exam.
Sure. I'll just talk with the team whether it'll be
morning or evening, okay?
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Okay. We'll see you on Monday then.
Thank you.
Yeah, sir. Also Saturday we have a class in the evening
from 7 45 to nine 15 different class,
Uh, 7 45, which, which course class,
Uh, LRS, uh, literature review seminar taken
by, uh, personas, sir.
Uh, okay.
Then, uh, what to do you people,
we'll, we'll discuss on Monday.
Okay? We are exceeding the time. We'll discuss it.
Previous, uh, test was conducted on weekdays, sir,
actually previous test for, uh, deep learning.
Mm-hmm. It was conducted in weekdays Monday, I think.
Uh, we'll discuss that. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank You, sir. Goodnight.
Thank you. Thank you, sir. Thank you.